tout vient tu attends qui
elle existe pas
l'expression les personnaliser tout
vient à point à qui sait attendre pardon
c'est le synonyme de patience de
persévérance
je les personnaliser parce que ça
résonne plus dans mon esprit avec le mot
de temps vous allez comprendre pourquoi
avec un petit peu de patience
aujourd'hui on est dans un système
l'écosystème où on veut tout tout de
suite
ou en tout cas on nous demande de tout
obtenir tout de suite c'est comme ça
faut composer avec
[Applaudissements]
je suis le premier à vouloir tout tout
de suite et je suis particulièrement
impatient
en classe ils ont le terme
j'ai regardé derrière moi pour savoir de
quoi j'allais vous parler et je me suis
rendu compte en fait les grands lignes
de ma vie j'ai que 34 ans j'ai peut-être
rien à vous apprendre en tout cas pas de
leçons à vous donner tout a été
construit par la patience
j'ai grandi à evian j'étais vraiment pas
doué pour l'école et puis j'avais pas
forcément de passion particulière
le seul point où j'arrive à me démarquer
c'était le sport ou là pour une fois je
n'étais pas le dernier de la classe
alors mes parents m'ont proposé de faire
du sport le plus économique parce que je
venais d'une famille modeste
c'est l athlétisme et puis le plus
proche parce que stade était à 50 mètres
de chez noir tout me suis mis à faire de
l'athlétisme en parallèle où je faisais
aussi de jets j'allais aussi à l'épaule
et je n'étais pas doué mais je
commençais à me démarquer en sport et
j'ai construit mon noyau social autour
du sport en tout cas sur le stand j'ai
rencontré benoît
c'était mon meilleur ami et puis toute
une bande à la version on a rigolé on a
progressé en sport ensemble en sport je
mets volontairement l'école de côté
parce que c'est pas très passionnant
j'étais nul
par contre le sport commencer un petit
peu a évolué en même temps que mes
collègues sans pour autant que
distinguer et puis à un jour ou l'autre
il fallait que ça arrive mais benoît
mais pardon mes amis à eux qui étaient
plutôt doué pour l'école contrairement à
moi est plutôt riche faut dire ce qui
est tout l'opposé de moi mais pourtant
amis mais il fallait qu'il parte
un jour pour faire des études donc je me
suis retrouvé tout seul tout seul à
faire uniquement du sport bon j'en ai vu
un petit peu marre je voulais arrêter
mais j'avais que ça parce que l'école
toujours pareil je n'avais pas évolué et
je me démarque est pas par l'école donc
j'ai continué avec un petit peu de
patience vous entraîneurs m'ont motivé
et j'ai je m'étais fixé un objectif qui
était le premier de décrocher un bep
modestement
c'était la seule voie qu'on m'avait
proposé ou en tout cas que j'étais
capable de 1 de poursuivre et puis en
sport j'avais un objectif c'était de
faire champion de mareuil c'est un petit
peu plus élevé que ça parce que mon
objectif en réalité c'était d'avoir le
maillot de l'équipe de france et par le
travail
l'entraînement en tout cas et la
patience j'ai réussi à obtenir ce
maillot de l'équipe de france j'ai couru
pour la france en sprint court et vite
j'essayais de défier le temps
au bout d'un moment mon coach m'a
proposé de d'aller plus loin et de venir
s'installer à aix les bains pour
progresser encore et encore j'ai
décroché mon bébé et puis je suis rentré
dans une filière un peu plus générale où
j'ai passé mon bac stt en parallèle je
faisais aussi du sport je sais pas si
vous vous faites du sport à sport études
ça implique de faire des études des
devoirs et puis de faire du sport tous
les soirs le lundi le mardi le mercredi
le jeudi le vendredi le samedi et le
dimanche le lundi le marathon suite
c'est très lourd et j'ai progressé et
j'ai pris confiance en moi de nouveau et
à l'école je m'en sortais un petit peu
mieux je j'avais envie de travailler je
m'intéressais à de plus en plus de
choses jusqu'à ce que j'intègre
réellement l'équipe de france parce que
pour la première fois c'était un
accident
et puis pour la seconde fois j'étais
impliqué au sein de l'équipe de france
jusqu'à ce que j'arrive aux portes de
l'équipe de france élite parce
qu'auparavant c'était pour les jeunes
avec un objectif en tête c'est être
couvrir les jeux olympiques et je me
suis entraîné j'ai continué à avoir une
progression linéaire
je me suis inscrit à un dut donc à
technolac techniques de
commercialisation
et j'ai abouti à un objectif crucial qui
est de faire les jeux olympiques
j'ai participé pour la france aux jeux
olympiques de pékin
au 100 m petite anecdote
[Musique]
alors ce qui pourrait paraître un
aboutissement ne l'étaient en réalité
pas parce que c'était quasiment une fin
pour moi une fin en soi j'ai rempli mon
objectif j'avais plus envie dégoût total
de l'effort pour autant j'avais pas
forcément passions à autre que le sport
même si le sport en soit ce n'était pas
une passion c'était juste un moyen pour
moi de pouvoir vivre et puis d'un de
pouvoir me démarquer me distinguer
c'était vraiment une recherche de
reconnaissance
alors j'ai continué à gronder espoirs de
ma femme que j'ai rencontrée pendant
cette période j'ai continué pourquoi
allez savoir pourquoi
aujourd'hui je le sais mais si vous avez
un peu de patience vous allez comprendre
pourquoi
entre temps j'ai commencé à travailler
j'ai arrêté les études j'étais pas fait
courant de toute manière et puis j'avais
envie de travailler puis avoir un
salaire et à un jour on m'appelle pour
ça pour faire un constat c'était que
j'étais plutôt en fin de carrière
athlétique
je vais réussir à garder un niveau
constant le pilote de bobsleigh
delaplane m'appelle pour savoir si
j'accepterai tous les sons bobsleigh
courir vite et puis faire des descentes
sur les fesses et j'ai accepté faire des
tests jusqu'à des sélections pour les
jeux olympiques d'hiver
ma carrière de bobsleigh qui a duré six
mois et participer aux jeux olympiques
d'hiver
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors sur la partie sport il c'est
pareil c'est pas une leçon c'est un
constat c'est que j'ai commencé le
champion ma rue et j'ai fini double
olympien dans deux sports différents et
de deux olympiades différentes donc ça
va sans rechercher de reconnaissance il
vous en trouvez vous croiserez pas
beaucoup dans la rue sauf peut-être si
dans l'amphithéâtre il ya des projets en
tout cas je vous souhaite bon courage
suite à quoi effectivement la page sport
c'est entre guillemets fermé parce que
c'est pas terminé
en tout cas pas pour l'effort les forges
mais je l'avais mis de côté j avais plus
beau pendant que je travaillais donc je
travaillais en banque
j'avais suivi un cheminement un peu
linéaire comme dans le sport commencé au
tout début je n'étais pas forcément doué
dans la banque et j'ai persévéré j'ai
été patient et puis j'ai gravi les
échelons jusqu'à l'arrivée un poste
quasiment deux conseillers en gestion de
patrimoine
donc c'est pas ce n'est pas non plus
exceptionnel mais dumont niveau scolaire
est entre guillemets intellectuelle
quand même pas donné à 10 minutes
différemment que ça ait un jour on
m'appelle à manu je sais que tu as
commencé à développer un talent
commercial dans la banque
je connais ses qualités dans le sport
qui pourrait vite tu t'y connais un
petit peu je voudrais savoir s'il
accepterait de travailler pour moi
à
dans la start-up que je représente que
j'ai créée il se trouve que ces
start-ups et la première licorne en
suisse une licorne c'est une société qui
valorise à plus d'un milliard d'euros
j'ai accepté forcément avec un salaire
suivre je ne pouvais pas renoncer
c'était quand même un choix de vie parce
que j'avais des enfants qui vous met le
challenge était beau et puis j'ai pris
goût au challenge vous que au fur et à
mesure j'ai réussi à aboutir à ce que je
vois ce que je voulais le plus beau dans
cette histoire parce qu'aujourd'hui je
suis toujours salarié de cette start up
et j'espère que cette progression va
être linéaire comme le reste de ma
carrière a les plus beaux de cette
histoire c'est que mon employeur
c'est benoît s'étaient quittés voilà nos
schèmes nos chemins s'étaient séparés à
lui 1 est têtue intellectuelle qui avait
fait polytechnique et moi qui étais à
mon niveau
donc voila c'était le petit l'a eue
c'est presque un roman c'est ce schéma
quasi linéaire qui ressemble beaucoup au
temps j'ai pas envie d'y mettre un point
parce que la voix l'expression c'est
tout vient à point
j'ai envie que ça se poursuive autant
que possible donc voila quand
j'utilisais je n'ai pas de leçon à vous
donner par contre vous tous peut-être
qu'un jour vous poserez les mêmes
questions mois à reviens tu es derrière
vous et qui a fait de vous à moi ce qui
a fait les grandes étapes de votre vie
et je le suis presque sûr que la
patience avoir un gros enjeu merci